TONIGHT'S CONVERSATION.
LET'S START WITH THE BIG EVENT.
THIS WAS A COMBINATION OF
THINGS.
FOR DECADES AMERICA WAS RUN BY
AN ESTABLISHMENT IDEALOLOGY OF
GLOBALIZATION.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS A LOT
FAVORED BUSINESS AND TECHNOLOGY
AND CENTRALIZATION OF POWER IN
THE ADMINISTRATIVE STATE.
ALSO A READY SUPPLY OF CHEAP
IMPORTANT LABOR.
THIS BROUGHT HUGE BENEFITS TO
THE ELITE THEMSELVES.
TO THE 80% OF THE AMERICANS
OUTSIDE OF THE KNOWLEDGE
ECONOMY.
INCOMES WENT DOWN, JOBS WENT
AWAY, AND THE SOCIAL FABRIC WAS
DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED TO OVER
TURN THIS ELITIST IDEALOLOGY.
THIS WEEK IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
THE ELITE HAS A NEW IDEOLOGY.
THIS TIME IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH POLICY.
IT'S MUCH SIMPLER AND LESS
RATIONAL.  IT'S HATED OF DONALD
TRUMP AND HIS FOLLOWERS.
THEY SAY THEY FEAR STRANGERS.
IS THERE ANY BETTER DEPICTION OF
HOW SENIOR FBI OFFICERS KNOWN AS
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE LAZY,
UNEDUCATED, P.O.S. PIECES OF
S-H-I-T.
THEY FAWN OVERCOME BY.
HE PUT HIMSELF ABOVE THE LAW.
THEY JUST HATE TRUMP.
THEY SAY HE'S UNDERMINING
DEMOCRATIC NORMS.
THIS PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED TO
THE CONSTITUTION.
THEY HATE TRUMP.
THIS WEEK THEY CONDEMNED HIM FOR
BEING NICE THE KIM JONG-UN.
THERE IS MUCH MORE CRUELTY IN
CHINA.
THE ELITE WAS AVOIDING NUCLEAR
WAR.
THE ELITE CHINA HAD WAS GREED.
LOOK AT WHAT BILL SAID.
HOPING FOR A RECESSION SO DONALD
TRUMP DOESN'T GET CREDIT FOR
HELPING WORKING AMERICANS.
NANCY IS TRYING TO TURN ANYTHING
POSITIVE INTO A NEGATIVE.
NOT EVEN LESS RISK OF NUCLEAR
WAR MATTERS TO THESE ELITEST.
THAT IS THE NEW ELITEST